this is the big one and this isn't a
free agency transaction it's an
agreement to engage in a trade when the
league year begins 4:00 p.m. Eastern on
Wednesday
DeForest Buckner from the 49ers to the
Indianapolis Colts for a first-round
pick after the 49ers did a five-year 85
million dollar deal with Arik Armstead
Buckner breaks the bank it's a real 21
million dollar per year deal for
DeForest Buckner and a stunner
a stunner this is the stunner I was
referring to earlier today I thought the
stunner involves somebody else but this
is the stunner are you stunned I can't
say that I'm stunned I can't say I you
know I wondered throughout this whole
process how the 49ers were gonna sign
all these guys I mean you know how much
money can you a lot to the defensive
line position alone hey I'm all for
having depth and talent on the defensive
line but at some point it's going to
compromise other areas of your football
team and I think the 49ers were
dangerously on the verge there so I
think the first thing I thought of was
when I saw Arik Armstead sign the
five-year 85 million dollar deal I
believe like you said I went oh well
they're not gonna franchise the forest
Buckner - I mean are they really gonna
have like 60 something million dollars
tied up in defensive ends or something
like that a lot alone you know - top
three draft picks at the position as
well that didn't make sense to me
so I was expecting to hear something I
had no idea was gonna happen today and I
did not know it was gonna be the Colts
it's it's a great move by the Colts and
the 49ers I mean that's the first thing
I'll say the Colts need a
difference-maker in their front seven
they got a lot of good they got nobody
that's great and they got all this money
to spend and I think this is a good
start for them right here to spend it
wisely and improve their football team
yeah and this is something that Colts
don't do Chris Ballard's GM of the team
resist spending big money early and free
agency and this really isn't an early
and four agency deal because it's not a
free agency deal but it is top of the
market just behind Aaron Donald for an
interior defensive lineman and a
first-round pick given up to
to force Buckner that's what makes this
Astana this is the kind of investment
that these cults have not been making
Chris no you're right I mean Chris
Ballard is usually a total value type
guy but he probably looks at his roster
and goes man I got a lot of value I've
done a lot of good things here in my
start with the cults I need to start
getting guys who can win us football
games when it's 20 to 17 in the fourth
quarter and we're beating the Houston
Texans I need a guy that can go Corral
deshaun Watson and make the big stop to
where we can get off the field and win a
football game so I'm sure he recognized
that and you know within that okay I
commend them for the move I think it's a
big-time move is it a little rich for me
yeah it is I don't think the forest
Buckner in my eyes all right or my
evaluation of you know film and naam Ron
Jaworski I watched the film right as we
always have fun fun with but just
comparatively speaking okay you know the
good thing is he has positioned
versatility which I love for the Colts
but I do still think it's expensive do I
think he's as good a player as Grady
Jarrett arond Donald Hakeem Hicks who
played the same position he does in
football no for me I think he's a notch
down from those guys but nonetheless
it's a new year he's one of the big free
agents at hit or you know one of the big
acquisitions at his position and he's
gonna get paid accordingly so good for
him and look this is something the 49ers
are gonna have to deal with
I thought they'd let Arik Armstead walk
and keep DeForest Buckner but when it
comes down to it five years 85 or 21
million a year for Buckner the 49ers in
position to best know which of the guys
they want to keep and really you could
argue you don't need either guys long as
you have Dee Ford and nicmos on the
outside you could find guys to put in
the inside and they're gonna face single
team they're gonna face reduced
attention it's gonna be easier for them
to do their jobs because everybody is
gonna be obsessed primarily with
stopping Nick Bosa yeah well that's
right Bose is the best player on their
football team and I mean I think you
could already make a case that he's one
of the two or three best defensive
players and all football you know maybe
with Aaron Donald and Khalil Mac and
probably a few up Stephon Gilmore I mean
he's in that con
you know you always need interior d-line
you always need some sighs we know
Buckner Armstead our giant human beings
I mean we saw them in person on the
divisional playoff games I mean I always
call them tree trunks because that's
what they look like
they're gigantic you know I think
ultimately you know obviously the 49ers
must have had some inkling that Buckner
was going to ask for too much money and
that's why they decided go with Armstead
and move on from Buckner but the value
of these guys though Mike like Armstead
and Buckner - is it just gives you the
great versatility to go okay we're
playing a passing team this week okay
now we can lead d Ford and Nick Bose on
the outside and now we got Arik Armstead
in the middle to be a disrupter oh no
now this week we're playing let's say
the Tennessee Titans in a power running
team and you want to get big up front
okay well now maybe we can move to
Forrest Buckner you know to defend to
end we can move deep deep forward out -
linebacker Nick Bose will be the other
DN and now we could have two other
Trudie tackles in the middle to get big
and stop that type of team so I think
that's really the value in those type of
guys it's that versatility to where they
can be a mismatch inside in the pass
game and then be a mismatch on the edge
in the run game and that's where their
real value is
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports